very ignorant way to think totally you
know yeah and then they wouldn't want to
say that on my face cuz they wouldn't
want to smoke either so that's what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying so you
know it's a very ignorant way to think
and you're you're limiting yeah your
potential your Viewpoint and hurting us
as a people because we should be able to
rise above and play to the highest
common denominator and not dumb
ourselves down most those fools aren't
even as freaking Hood as like you know
what I'm saying they don't know what it
is you got to be out there and look at
yourself as a brand and as a commodity
to appeal to everyone do not limit
yourself cuz you're short changing
yourself I'm trying to cash those checks
everywhere I don't want to just be in
one exactly have it in one Revenue
stream trying to host Oscars you know
what I'm saying you know so that's what
I'm saying so any like young Latino kids
out there you can keep it real and you
can do what you want and have different
but hey be smart enough to know you want
to make real money get that corporate
money you